il est le troisième représentant de
l'état est remise en cause dans la mort
de steve majaka dissous en juin 2019
claude d'harcourt le préfet de
loire-atlantique en poste au moment du
drame a été mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire
pour rappel steve
est tombé dans la loire au cours d'une
intervention de police le soir de la
fête de la musique on en parle tout de
suite avec cécile de oliveira avocate de
la famille de steve
mauges en maths m et merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors tout d'abord
quelle est votre réaction suite à la
mise en examen de l'ancien préfet pour
homicide involontaire
alors ma réaction fait qu'un la faire
avant tu as une vitesse qui est tout à
fait respectable et raisonnable au
regard des la compétivité de
l'instruction ça c'est ma première
réaction est ma deuxième réaction c'est
à dire que la famille de ce type media
can i saw est soulagé de la prise en
compte par la justice à ce stade de la
gravité et de
[Musique]
évidemment la tragédie causée par cette
charge policière la famille peut
commencer à faire son deuil et ce qu'ils
ont l'impression que enfin la justice et
est rendu aujourd'hui à steve alors la
justice n'est pas rendue l'a rendue
quand tu auras une décision de justice
définitive ce n'est pas le cas on est
dans un cadre d'instruction après la
question du deuil j'ai une question
intime et complexes et demi avant c'est
évidemment comme toute la nuit choqué
par une mort tragique avec ses souvenirs
la justice joue un rôle bien sûr mais je
sais pas un rôle des médias est
automatique en tout cas au fil des
auditions de déroulement des faits se
précise
quelle est la suite aujourd'hui
la suite donnée videmment la continuité
de cette information judiciaire et à
l'issue nous verrons quelles sont les
personnes qui seront renvoyés pour être
jugé devant le tribunal correctionnel
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour votre
témoignage cécile de oliveira je
rappelle que vous êtes l'avocate de la
famille de steve mailhac ali sow